okay so i tweeted and you guys gave me a
question to ask them still so we're here
good question
oh wow okay wait here let me get in get
in for these answers we're talking
cooked hot sandwich or cold from a
service station sandwich i don't know no
what's any type of sandwich
no it's
like a good is that a good new york
reuben
okay you know
that much meat and the bread's just like
a garnish
yeah yeah pork sandwich okay that sounds
good
i'm gonna say chicken oh
like a mcchicken like like from
mcdonald's
really
do you find that
mcdonald's or like chain restaurants in
the us are different than anywhere else
so they're just better here really we
can't get double-course founders in
england because our governments say you
shouldn't be fat you've turned into a
flatbed
and in america i'm free to make that
choice and i do
create a lot of them very true it's
gonna be the boxing day special
whatever's left from christmas smash it
into some bread very good doesn't matter
what it is a great gravy boat a whole
gravy boat
that's a world you get bread butter it
up mayo a slice of pizza maybe a bit
more mayo another slice of bread pizza
sandwich that sounds like you're going
to go into cardiac arrest immediately
look at him because he eats a lot of
pizza sandwiches oh pizza do you guys
have having fun and hang out first yeah
it's amazing i mean this couldn't be
more different from english festivals if
they tried
we're used to being in a muddy field
with drunk people and hairy ass boy
beach this is amazing you're at the
beach with drunk people that's amazing
all right guys well thank you so much
have an amazing show
foreign
oh
you